you guys are now two for two working
together i've made a joke about this on
twitter but what do uh what do i need to
do and what do fans need to do to get
you guys to make more movies together no
i don't think anybody needs to do
anything uh we all we want to do our
movies together we're very lucky that we
have some some films in development
um ones that aren't just that sort of
you know
development kind of projects that just
vaporize uh down the road these are real
ones that we cannot wait to make
together so um we we're lucky we're very
lucky that we
found each other at this stage in our
careers where it's just it is uh it's
unlike any kind of work relationship
i've ever had and i've had some great
ones
uh so i just but i just adore working
with sean and i hope i hope that i get
to make you know as many movies as
humanly possible as many as i'm allowed
to make uh i hope they're with sean
can i ask is there something that you
guys are really on the cusp of maybe
doing together or is everything still in
like far development
i mean i guess it depends on how you
define far right ryan um for us i mean
look i've been on stuff
where you're gestating for five years
and i would say most of the stuff that
ryan and i are working on together feels
nearer horizon than that um i think the
only one kind of you know that that we
have kind of spoken about is definitely
we loved free guy we were thrilled that
free guy um was as successful as it was
and particularly as an original movie um
at a time where few get made and even
fewer are hit so that was gratifying and
if we can crack that sequel that's
something that might be very fun to to
to make together but um it all feels you
know there's a few and and none of them
feel like distant hypotheticals when you
agree ryan they all feel like oh no it's
just a matter of sequencing not so much
if
well we've also been around the block
enough to know not to get into that sort
of slippery slope of you know
abstract obscure you know unreal
development projects this is this is you
know the things that we're getting
involved with our stories that we really
want to tell stories that you know the
studios that we're talking to are ready
to go as soon as we're ready to go we
just most for us it's mostly just about
getting the stories right script is
right before you go to camera because
that's everything you know you don't we
we both know that that is also that is
an equally slippery slope is is heading
into physical production before
uh before something's truly ready
what i definitely you brought up free
guy and i i that was on my list to talk
about because uh people might not
realize it was the highest grossing
original movie during the pandemic i
believe it made 331 million dollars
which is a huge amount of money how much
has disney been calling you guys saying
um yes so we really do want that sequel
and we really want you filming it like
next year i've definitely gotten that
phone call
i mean i don't know how to quantify that
how much but that exact phone call that
you just basically paraphrased that's a
call i've gotten a few of those in the
past several months so there is
definitely real interest there but to
ryan's point
we kind of knew we we had such a clear
idea of the tone the story the details
of free guys so uh uh and we both made a
few sequels in our lives and so we know
how hard it is to make a worthy one and
when we feel confident that that's the
kind we'll make then we'll make it